trying to go behind the sides to shoot
our video but it looking stop trying to
make behind the signs happen this is a
set for a play like we hit some fun oh
yeah we had this in a small theater it
seems like a really good place to make a
video I don't have my line that's
something I definitely don't know what
I'm doing I don't know how any this
works I heard voices I heard a lot of
voices behind that door it was locked
I'm gonna run away morning John it's
Tuesday you look great okay this is
happening hey before we start the video
Nerdist I just want to get rid of the
elephant in the room and acknowledge
that yes I have shaped my moustache I'm
so nervous that people are gonna walk in
that door if they do its phone almost
never in my life have I not been nervous
when Hank was nervous this is a very new
feeling for me pineapple or no I'm sorry
Nick what was the late swim it's
question Tuesday the day we answer real
questions from real nerdfighters
pineapple or no yeah pineapples exist or
or like it's not the option you either
have pineapple use of the word no mmm I
take a pineapple I might take no I find
no to be a very useful word what's your
pizza eating method John I take it off
and I roll it up and then I slice it so
that it's like like a cinnamon roll of
Pete's Hank is so nervous right now I
just want to get the video over with so
we can get out of here before we get
caught
there is no getting caught we are where
we are supposed to I had to take my shoe
off the block adult opinions on next day
Pizza Oh strongly Pro reheated or cold
just pulled out of the fridge and eaten
oh it's in the fridge oh god yes Hank
will eat anything like we go to gas
stations on tour and Hanks like can I
have this corn dog that's been slowly
rotating for 14 hours
they don't rotate the corn box they just
keep them under the heat trap the hot
dogs get rolled around how do I mean
that's the kind of thing you shouldn't
know because you shouldn't eat that
stuff in gas stations what is it there
that John
what would you do inside a whale Oh
panic how did I get there did I get
swallowed yeah like what part of the way
on my end right if I like next to the
but can I get out the but hearts are big
enough to you probably be in the whale a
or not in the whale and then it's a bad
day for the whale right the whale says
thank you to them that fast and I just
get caught downstream like been one of
the Junction's right in the nuts wheels
have nuts no in my nuts a blood vessel
split and my legs go on either side oh
yeah do the splits and also yes whales
have knots great good to know they're on
the inside and people say you don't
learn anything from bug but there's
videos would you rather have a pizza
sized John or a John sized pizza it's an
interesting question what you would do
in real life if suddenly a miniature
version of yourself sure you wouldn't do
with anything with and you would have to
let it decide what to do for itself
right you have you have to be like Go Go
three keys yeah out of me and if you
love me you'll come back have you ever
eaten real pizza in Italy I have yeah it
had too many olives on it it was
basically in Holland I find Italian
beats it to be a little bit overrated to
be honest with you America we don't make
stuff we make stuff better that's a
great line it's not always true but it
doesn't really matter whether it's true
it matters whether it sounds good
welcome to 2017 is it true that whale
nuts are on the inside yes that is true
how do you know that have you ever seen
a whale I looked it up I know the honest
with the answer is that I lived it up
when I leg up one down was like where
are whale nuts and I found out where
they were why do you think this is for
Hank ah like Arsenic and Old Lace Death
of a Salesman yeah it could be that at
any rate Hank I I'm glad that we got to
perform unexpectedly on this stage you
know what it seems like to me is the
kind of formal living room where like
anytime you sat down in it as a kid you
knew you were in trouble or that your
hamster died right we had something
serious to talk to you about your
terrible dog ate your beloved hamster we
do have to go on the stage now we do not
this stage the real one yeah yeah we yep
goodbye John I'll see you now there I am
Oh God